c'est les indices d'or et Cyril parfois
vous savez
sur ma vie
je crois je prends jusqu'à 10h
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
une petite boulette
Cyril parfois on a des fous un homme
parce que j'ai trois dents en moins donc
parfois on a des cons on a des fous
rires qui sont incontrôlables vous savez
vous avez tous connu cette sensation des
fous rires on devrait pas avoir courir
mais qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu peux pas
manger par Macron donc parfois on a des
fous rires dans des situations un peu
relou ça a été votre cas en Cyril voilà
une pub
un extrait qui a été envoyé avec un
lancement un peu approximatif et du coup
Cyril a eu un gros fou rire pendant le
magnéto évidemment vous l'aviez pas vu à
la maison mais je suis payé pour ça
un fou rire au mauvais moment c'est en
numéro 4 numéro 4 numéro 4
[Musique]
mais non c'est numéro 4
sinon ça c'est bon Castalie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette année on avait vu également Gilles
Verdez non pas se prendre avant mais
sous le vent
[Musique]
es
de Mathieu Delormeau dans sa salle de
sport et c'est fou il a toujours le
marron celui-ci
[Rires]
et enfin on avait vu Cyril préparer les
fêtes de fin d'année avec un petit pas
dedans regardez-moi ça
quand je suis dans la cuisine
on passe tout de suite au numéro 4
puisque après le 7 c'est le 4
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible
donc je disais il y a quelques instants
que parfois on a des fous rires un peu
relou c'est arrivé à Cyril avec un
extrait où il fallait pas partir en
forêt c'est le numéro 4 numéro 4 numéro
Pascal praut invité la doyenne de
l'humanité et vous allez voir elle pète
la force nous sommes avec la doyenne de
l'humanité sœur André puisse
se rendrait est né en 1904
alors les chéris
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est vrai
pendant une publicité dans le top 3
numéro 3
on les mettra sur le sur facebook
tirer les Mathieu ont décidé de faire un
petit jeu pendant une publicité les tu
préfères vous connaissez le jeu tu
préfères normalement c'est 03 c'est
entre deux propositions qui sont relous
sauf que les propositions de n'étaient
pas du tout relou il y avait un choix
qui paraissait quand même logique
tourner comme ça c'était peut-être un
peu plus gros et je peux vous dire
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
tout le monde veut le piège
vas-y fais-le fais-le fais-le monsieur
là
[Musique]
tu préfères coucher avec Daniel Moreau
en même temps enfin le truc en même
temps
je peux faire ça toute la soirée t'as
pas le choix sinon toute ta famille ok
toute ta famille toute ta famille elle
brûle sauf si
toi tu couches avec Daniel Moreau il y a
eu 8 morts cette année c'est ça
mais je dis c'est complètement con mais
lui mais c'est con lui dit
[Rires]
et sachez que franchement je me pose la
question je rigole pas ma chérie je te
jure je pose la question franchement
Daniel est magnifique et Daniel tu sais
si je prendrai pas autant de temps avec
toi si tu me plaisais pas un ton soit
peu
pas mal voilà tu prends comme tu veux
maintenant tu vis avec ça avant de
passer à la numéro 1 la numéro 2
évidemment avec une des séquences qui a
marqué l'année c'était il y a un peu
plus d'un mois à recevait une star
internationale sur ce plateau qui nous a
offert une séquence incroyable Afida
Turner
[Musique]
de la prestation de la finale c'était
les tetés de tout le monde regardez bien
les réactions parfois une Immo une image
vaut mieux que mille mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends attends attends attends attends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un feat entre Guillaume Genton
Nicolas pernica et Cyril Hanouna alors
on a un débat Nicolas bernikov a laissé
un peu ses émotions le dépasser et il
n'en a pas fallu beaucoup à cirer la
Nouna pour ressortir son côté qui est
assez rare son côté mauvaise foi je vous
laisse regarder c'est l'American staff
évidemment
[Musique]
on est en train de les mélanger les uns
avec les autres
c'est passé il a eu peur il a sauté sur
le truc mais tu ne peux pas derrière la
mairie pour le fait que c'est un chien
qui ne risque rien Nicolas ça vous fait
marrer
ça te fait marrer
monsieur
aujourd'hui les Américains stuff on est
en train de les mélanger les uns avec
les autres
dans une cité dans la rue on ne peut pas
les trouver le chien seul il y a un
moment donné quelque part
il a sauté sur le truc mais tu ne peux
pas faire rire à la mairie pour le fait
que c'est un chien qui ne risque rien
mais Nicolas ça vous fait marrer
ça te fait marier ça te fait marrer
[Applaudissements]
oh il y a merci mon chéri